côte d'ivoire à présent avec une
situation très tendue et des
affrontements post électoraux on
dénombre des morts le bras de fer entre
le pouvoir et les opposants ne cesse de
se durcir l'opposition qui a boycotté le
scrutin refuse de reconnaître la
victoire d'alassane ouattara pour un
troisième mandat proclamés par la
commission électorale indépendante
les forces de l'ordre se sont déployées
devant les domiciles de plusieurs
opposants sur place nos 2 envoyé spécial
samantha ramsamy chronique ou alors
c'est très tendue dans la capitale on
s'en aperçoit bien c'est vraiment
compliqué maintenant de travailler de
réaliser des duplex de couvrir à fait
tension politique post électorale on est
de retour ici à l'hôtel tout à l'heure
en fait pour vous expliquer la situation
on a et tenter de réaliser un duplex
devant le siège du pdc y le parti de
l'ancien président henri konan-bédié
nous étions installés depuis plus de
trente minutes et c'est vrai que il ya
des jeunes des personnes qui se sont
approchés de nous et juste au moment où
le duplex a commencé et bien ils ont
tout fait pour nous empêcher de
travailler c'est pourquoi nous sommes
partis pour notre sécurité et donc on
est retourné à l'hôtel
c'est vrai que hier soir déjà on nous on
a pu observer dans le quartier de cocody
des tensions entre des jeunes en colère
et les forces de l'ordre qui ont chargé
dans le quartier de cocody et qui ont
utilisé des gaz lacrymogènes dimanche
les forces de police ont dispersé des
journalistes des militants devant le la
résidence d'henri konan bédié
les forces de l'anp qui se sont alors
déployés dans la rue juste donc qui fait
face à sa résidence
elles sont encore là ce matin on a
vérifié par nous mêmes on est allé du
côté
la rue donc ils mènent à la résidence de
l'ancien président on a pu échanger
quelques mots avec les forces de l'ordre
qui nous ont demandé de nous éloigner
nous ont bien indiqué qu'on pouvait pas
travailler ici en tout cas je peux vous
assurer que le secteur il est
complètement bouclée il ya donc
plusieurs résidences d'opposants qui
serait encerclé encore ce matin salle
par exemple d'assoa adou le secrétaire
exécutif du pdc y celle d'albert mabri
toikeuse qui est une personnalité
politique en vue ici en côte d'ivoire un
opposant également et puis la résidence
de pascal affi n'guessan vous savez le
leader d'une frange de l'opposition de
franche du front populaire ivoirien
plusieurs hauts cadres du pdci le parti
d'henri konan bédié qui ont été arrêtés
hier par les autorités ivoiriennes ça
s'est passé à la résidence de l'ancien
président alors que se déroulaient des
consultations sur ce fameux gouvernement
de transition civile lancé par pascal
affi n'guessan pascal affi n'guessan et
et henri konan-bédié ce sont les deux
candidats sur les quatre en lice samedi
dernier qui n'ont pas voté il refuse de
reconnaître la victoire d'alassane
ouattara qui a été proclamée par la
commission électorale indépendante
d'après le camp d'henri konan bédié il y
aurait 7 il aurait eu cette arrestation
pour trouble à l'ordre public et complot
contre l'autorité de l'état certains
auraient été relâchés après un
interrogatoire
ce que l'on sait en tout la cecc henri
konan-bédié il est bien dans sa
résidence il n'a pas lui était arrêté
en revanche pascal affi n'guessan qui se
trouvait chez lui et bien la police est
venue le chercher pour un interrogatoire
avant de le relâcher
l'opposition qui dénonce clairement des
tentatives d'intimidation
cette anecdote encore lundi soir par
exemple moi je me suis entretenu avec
les équipes d'henri konan bédié
ils m'ont signalé que des crs ont passé
dans la rue il ya eu des tirs de
sommations qui aurait fait trembler les
vitres de la résidence le porte-parole
adjoint du gouvernement ivoirien m'a
bien confirmé la présence des crs sur
place mais selon lui pour disperser des
individus qui étaient sur les lieux
les autorités qui dénonce une sédition
de l'opposition d'ailleurs elle nous
invite ses autorités cet après midi à
venir échanger avec elles lors d'un
point-presse encore dans le quartier de
cocody
on devrait donc s'y rendre sachez encore
que le consulat de france a appelé les
ressortissants français à éviter cette
zone de cocody